volevi registrare ecco non di rischio
sarà il cazzo quando registro sarebbe un
peccato se qualcuno ti scrivesse di
continuo in chat ti ammazzo anche i
parenti quelli lontani dalla city
ragazzi di questo video sono famigerati
siamo tornati su happy room che quel
gioco dove niente bisogna fare
ecco quanto prendere a schiaffi sta
ragazza non oso pensare da dove le tiri
fuori
l'obiettivo del gioco era di far male il
più possibile a questo personaggio è
l'ultima volta che l'ho fatto ho
scoperto che con le balestre facevo un
danno della madonna bene il record era
2.857 cosa che non batte roma mai male
anche se prego in cinese mandarino prova
a caricare di mitragliatrici ragazzi
solo ed esclusivamente prevedere quanto
danno fanno non so quanto possa
funzionare sta roba in realtà
facciamo che la balestra togliamo e
mettiamo solo le cose che ci si passano
da una parte all'altra che dite ok
spingi lo zio spingi spingi lo spingi
non ho ancora un po ancora un po corpo
perfetto ma non è bordello il portello
ha funzionato ragazzi come volevo fare
non so quanto danno in realtà li stanno
facendo non ne ho idea però è già
qualcosa cioè in senso rispetto a prima
che hanno fatto la mazza o le mitiche
bordello rega 2000 2006
l'unica regola visto gioco e stare zitti
per non tirarsi le cose io non so fare
mango duello solo per farvi rendere
conto di quello che sto dicendo c'è solo
per farvi rendere conto
va bene eh vabbè che cazzo è successo
c'è un disagio con del co ste robe
veramente un disastro fai un casino
tutte le frecce nel culo è fighissimo
trovare un modo per tenerlo in mezzo ho
messo anche ragazzi una molla che se vi
arriva a destra tipo meno sparano a
sinistra di prepotenza tipo adesso
perfetto o le interessa la tattica
dovrebbe abbastanza funziona non lo so
ok la clava per riparare una cava dove
sta clava bella così sta roba prova
forse roma ragazzi vedo se funziona è
quello che voglio fare non lo so e non è
da inter e non funziona in caso di gol e
voglio fare io ma va bene ma la sinistra
let's go relazionato sul serio non ci
credo era veramente questo livorno a
fermi tutti perfetta perfetta come ho
fatto a non battere no vabbè non è
possibile non ha battuto il record come
michael e spine perfetto 3 2 1 alessio
non c'è o che la madonna perfetto
perfetto perfetto è la mado sparato il
colpo con il problema non mi fa
incazzare era trigolo sparava sulle
spine una bomba no lui va a destra
ecco così perfetto perfetto ok ok ma che
non ero fate non rubate numero perfetto
va bene ottimo ottimo ottimo così ottimo
così continua stata su poi esploderà
tipo sia di sotto che di sopra la sua
tesi ore 18 perfetto perfetto ma si
finiva sulla mina e ancora meglio ma va
bene così imparerò a volare io ti
imparerò prima l'italiano zii rosberg
bel posto mettiamo sul blocco poco ok tu
quando vuoi fare l'acrobata basta che me
lo dici cambiamo gioco si ok anche nella
prima vedere se per te 519 milan elevato
ecco il blocco via alla fine serve a
questo sarà tenerlo fermo in teoria
apple viene da un cazzo di blocco b è
una merda teoria là sotto non ci
dovrebbe passare poi non lo so er area
3300 mila 3000 3000 dove cazzo finita la
testa cosa mi sfugge perché la mia testa
è diventata un cubo credo che si sia
fatto male ragazzi 3.900 mi sa di record
decisamente cella con mostro guatta fax
e novell e sap ed hoffer minerebbero
saperlo io cosa mica è uscito dall amica
pire cesto mostro che scorrazza per
tutto il campo cos'è mostro che
scorrazza per tutto il campo spiegami
che cosa è successo con la freccia che
fisica ciacco la freccia lì che la
madonna la madonna
credo che meglio di così non possa fare
perché io ho usati praticamente tutti
4193 orate ragazzi un po di scream che
mi avete mandato dopo l'ultimo video di
ep room è una delle cose di me ti
consente di fare per arrivare al tipo
non so quanto di punteggio e questa una
volta arrivati qua tac col teletrasporto
e vediamo
ma siamo sicuri che raggiungo alti
traguardi questa roba perché non ne sono
sicurissimo che varia dai fan
quanto tempo si pente sta roba non ho
idea
sorge un dubbio ma se io rimango così 12
anni questo mi arriva a 4000 mi batte
record
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi che posso concludere che
con questo video abbiamo raggiunto
record messo una vita in mezzo ho capito
in modi migliori per fare danni bastava
fa starmer data qua però va bene però
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi non mi piace
anche vari social come la posizione zero
se avessi iscrivetevi ci vediamo in
corsivo video grazie del suggerimento
dei portali con ci sarei mai arrivato in
questo cervello e mi trovo da ragazzi
[Musica]